bonsoir bertrand legrand un an après et
voilà on en est toujours là retour à la
case départ
retour à la case départ
ça vient juste confirmé une un échec qui
se plaint couronné en fait différente
absurdité qu'on a déjà dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises le défaut de masques
a des origines maintenant on a des
basques on peut au moins a remercié le
gouvernement pour ça on a des masques
c'est bien ça fait un an
on espère avoir des vaccins dans un an
on espère que l' isolement soit
suffisant des personnes positives
peut-être dans un an ou dans six mois je
sais pas très bien combien de temps il
faudra en tout cas effectivement on est
arrivé au point de non retour et on est
bien obligé aujourd'hui de confiner pour
pouvoir soulager les services de
réanimation
c'est un échec alors dans le même temps
effectivement on nous dit voilà qu'on
n'a pas priver notre liberté c'est du
confinement mais on nous laisse sortir
satisfaisant tout cas pour le médecin
que vous êtes il fallait
une fois qu'on a critiqué évidemment ce
que vous venez de faire et ce qu'on a
déjà fait sur ce plateau les mesures
passé c'était ce qu'il fallait faire ou
il fallait les plus loin au contraire
mon moins loin je vois que vous avez
vous même du mal à décrire la totalité
de des allers retours c'est
manifestement ce le couvre-feu et plus
tard mais le confinement est plus sévère
forme ne fait pas très clair on refera
qu'on lise le texte de décret pour bien
comprendre tous les tous les éléments de
toute façon lui fallait confiné là on
n'avait plus de peu d'autres
possibilités puisque la sécurité sociale
et des équipes de contact racing libérer
tout le monde à 10 jours alors que
certains étaient encore contagieux que
le médecin traitant ne voyait plus les
patients qui étaient directement gérée
par la sécu bon c'est normal à un non
médecins ne sait pas gérer une épidémie
c'est pas une grande nouvelle on a
essayé depuis le mois de septembre ça
marche pas en tête essayer de revenir à
des choses plus concrètes où le médecin
va gérer les personnes contagieuses et
redonner le droit de sortir aux
personnes contagieuses en attendant il
faut faire baisser effectivement le seul
moyen qu'on a de faire baisser à l'heure
actuelle au vu du nombre des fidèles de
l'épidémie du nombre de personnes
atteintes
c'est le confinement c'est bien
malheureux mais il ya que ça à faire il
ya certaines incohérences que le médecin
que vous êtes pourrait peut-être nous
aider à décrire on nous dit maintenant
qu'on peut prendre l'air que finalement
c'est pas grave c'est vrai qu'on a du
mal à comprendre au début les enfants
étaient privés de sport à l'école
maintenant ils ne le sont plus et
l'enfant est supposé sévir
comment comprendre alors si on se
reporte à l'interview que vous avez fait
il ya un an je vous avais déjà expliqué
que c'était un peu étonnant de voir
confiné quelqu'un seul sur un pédalo au
milieu de la mer met donc effectivement
en dehors le risque est assez faible
on sait qu'on a très peu de kloster qui
sont faits en extérieur que les clusters
qui l'ont fait en extérieur sont
essentiellement sur les regroupements
vraiment collé serré
ça sort et yves fait relativement
logique ça va c mais enfin entre temps
on a quand même eu des conflits de man
street on a eu des attestations d'une
heure donc à oui ou non je sais faut
être très clair que ça fait un an qu'on
fait plus rien de logique donc que
pendant un an il ya eu des choses
totalement illogique c'est à la limite
c'est devenu logique il n'y a pas de
problème de ce côté-là les logis cité
des prix mesures prises antérieurement
ça il n'y a pas de problème tout le
monde est d'accord
par contre là cette fois ci pour le coup
nous permettre aux gens de sortir sa
part est relativement logique en
extérieur sans regroupement c'est tout à
fait normal et puis il faut quand même
aussi relâché un peu la pression
par contre il faut insister pour les
auditeurs même si le gouvernement est un
peu une logique le virus ne se transmet
que lorsque l'on se regroupe et si peu
et si on quand on se regroupe en milieu
clos donc clairement ce qu'il faut c'est
éviter de se retrouver en réunion de
famille en réunion entre amis
parce que c'est le moment nous on a
besoin d'avoir cette baisse de
l'incidence et si vous attendez que
l'état baissent l'incidence vu que ça
fait un an qu'ils sont a réussi bon on
va peut-être éviter de compter sur eux
alors il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle ou pas à sa faim en fonction
reprise demain après-midi et des
vaccinations astrazeneca avec jean
castex en tête le médecin généraliste
que vous êtes s'en réjouit mais dans le
même temps un seul mot à la mode il va
falloir quand même convaincre vos
passions la confiance est un petit peu
entamée non franchement on est vraiment
confiant d'enlever dans le vaccin
astrazeneca on n'avait pas de souci
particulier quand ils l'ont arrêté très
sincèrement c'était une absurdité
complète et si vous lisez entre les
lignes ce que dit le
le m&a il ya clairement une condamnation
des états qui ont arrêté la vaccination
qui est dit entre les lignes
après c'est du politiquement correct
bien évidemment mais il n'y avait aucune
raison pour un risque si fier si faible
d'arrêter la vaccination
personnellement j'ai une liste
d'attentes de 400 personnes volontaires
pour être vacciné malheureusement
dimanche prochain je n'aurai que 50 de
vaccins si je suis bien livré demain
donc ma secrétaire s'est organisé pour
appeler demain 50 personnes donc ça
c'est pas difficulté non ce qu'on
voudrait vraiment c'est avoir des doses
peu importe le vaccin puisque encore une
fois il n'ya pas que le vaccin
astrazeneca faut pas oublier que le
vaccin finder ou moderne est tout à fait
injectable en cabinet médical de ville
et pour des raisons toujours aussi
logique on nous l'interdisent soi disant
parce qu'il faut pas remuer le flacon ça
devient vraiment ridicule après nous
avoir dit qu'il fallait le congelé à 80
degrés alors qu'il n'est pas content des
80 degrés dans aucun centre de
vaccination donc voilà si on pouvait
trouver un tout petit peu de logique
dans la vaccination se dépêcher vacciner
nos patients ce serait vraiment ce qu'il
ya de mieux et bien bon courage merci
bertrand le grand merci à vous d'avoir
été en direct avec nous